Hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. I want to do a short video on why we would recommend Cyrex testing.
There's other laboratories. I'm not just stuck on Cyrex labs, but there's other laboratories that will do antibody testing as well.
Cyrex does it well. In my book, I think they do it the best. That's why we use them when we test for antibodies.
So a little explanation of what we're testing for.
So an antigen is something that the immune system is trying to kill.
So back up a little bit. You have two different ways that you get rid of
things in your body that aren't supposed to be there. You have your immune system and you have your detoxification pathways.
Now typically
pesticides and chemicals and heavy metals and such are supposed to be
gotten rid of through your detoxification pathways.
But in the case of you being overwhelmed by a toxin, you are exposed to a lot of pesticides or something like that.
Then you can end up having an immune reaction against it.
When you have an immune reaction against it, you can create antibodies.
So an antibody is a protein that is produced by the immune system in response to the presence of an antigen.
That's the definition of an antibody.
But an antigen is anything that's in the body that's not supposed to be there.
Now I said pesticides and chemicals and things are supposed to go through your detox pathways,
but we're exposed to so many of those things.
It's not uncommon that we can create antibodies against them because they're prolonged
in the body, in the bloodstream, in the tissues that because our detox pathways are overwhelmed.
Good thing to do is to read my seven phases of detox book here.
Your immune system is supposed to make antibodies against viruses and bacteria and
pathogens that are killable because that's what your immune system does.
Your detoxification pathway gets rid of chemicals and non-living things.
Your immune system gets rid of living things, bacteria, viruses, pathogens,
microbes that are trying to reproduce in your body, make it a home and use you as a host.
That's what your immune system is supposed to do and your immune system will create antibodies
to do that. So that's what we're looking for. Are you inadvertently, is your immune system
inadvertently creating antibodies against things that it shouldn't create antibodies against?
And then worst-case scenario, are you creating antibodies against your own cells,
against your own tissues, against your own organs? That is what's called an autoimmune disease.
If you're making antibodies against your thyroid, that's measurable. We can measure TPO antibodies and
you have excess antibodies against your thyroid. You have Hashimoto's or Graves' disease.
I don't know what state you're in. So that's what we're looking for when we're looking at antibodies.
So briefly, when chemicals come into your body, they go into your cells and your immune system
will fire a reaction against it. Typically, you'll have what's called a TH1 response first
and then it can't kill it because it's not killable. And then you have a TH2 response if your detoxification
pathways can't get rid of it, then you have the B cell response and you start to make antibodies
against this thing. That's what we're talking about with your immune system. That's a normal response
of your immune system in the presence of an antigen that is a living organism. You have a TH1 response
in order to kill this pathogen and it's not able to kill the pathogen and a period of time goes by
and now you have a TH2 response to create antibodies so it can take the pathogen. That's what an antibody
does. It takes the pathogen so that now when you have a TH1 response,
there are your T cells and your macrophages and your natural killer cells are able to find it easier
and kill it. That's the whole purpose of antibodies. But if you're making antibodies against
your self tissue, you're destroying self tissue. If you're making antibodies against mercury or lead
or a pesticide, your immune system will fire to kill it. Well, those things aren't killable. They're
not living organisms. So you just create this inflammatory response and an upgrade of inflammation
to your body. That's one major reason why people have chronic inflammation. That chronic inflammation
is because they have antibodies to things that aren't killable like foods or chemicals. So every time
their immune system fires, you're going to try to kill that what you have antibodies for. And if it's
not killable, you just have this ramped up inflammation. So it's a good idea to try to test for those.
Here's a picture of making antibodies against a virus. Actually, I think a picture of the
coronavirus or something like that that somebody drew up. But you make antibodies against it,
so it tags the virus or the bacteria so that now it's more recognizable by the killer cells,
the macrophages. So you want antibodies against bacteria and viruses. That's really the definition
of a healthy immune response. I have a really healthy immune system. What does that mean?
Well, it really means I have a lot of antibodies against a whole bunch of different pathogens.
So next time somebody says do you have a healthy immune response, say yes, I have a lot of antibodies
against a whole bunch of pathogens. But we don't want to have a lot of antibodies against not living
things. And we certainly don't want to have antibodies against our old tissues. So that's what we
want to measure. We want to measure. Do I have antibodies against not living things or my old tissues?
That's what an antibody test is. Cyrix does that well. And they have a lot of tests. That's really
all they do is measure antibodies. That's what that lab does. They have a lot of different tests that
they call arrays. So here's a couple of them. The one on the left here is their food sensitivity test
it measures. It's called array 10. It measures a lot of different things. So 300 different things cooked
and raw foods and vegetables that you might not even feel like you have a tummy ache with when you eat.
But you have antibodies against them circulated in your bloodstream because it isn't blood test.
That every time you do eat them you fire a reaction. You cause more inflammation and more just this
whole negative cycle of inflammation takes place and it can cause pain. It can cause problems all
over your body. Array 11 is the chemical autoimmune reaction screen. So it's measuring Aflatoxins
different types of molds. And what is produced by molds and what is produced by bacteria from
aldehyde, a whole bunch of different chemicals that were exposed to in our environment that we really
shouldn't be exposed to or we should be excreted. But because we're exposed to so many different
chemicals our immune system or our detoxification pathways get overwhelmed. And these chemicals
linger in our body. Our immune system tries to kill them and of course they can't because they're not
there being things. And then we our B cell or our TH2 system fires we had have created antibodies
against things we never should have created antibodies against. And this causes a lot of problems
in health wise. There's a joint autoimmune reaction screen. It's testing for our
arthritic peptides and collagen complex. And there's a neurological autoimmune reactive screen.
This is a very serious one because if you have antibodies to your cerebellar cells that is a
major problem. So we see that a lot with chronic Lyme patients that have a lot of brain fog and
can't think straight and they have pain in all sorts of different areas. Well you could have damaged
microglial cells and you really should watch the video in this in this module on microglial priming
and inflammation and neurological inflammation because that goes into detail of damaged microglial
cells or primed microglial cells. That's a brain cell that is responsible for the immune reaction
of the brain. But once we have antibodies to the brain to brain different tissue then it's even
more serious. So this is a major issue why people have cognitive problems, why people have just all
sorts of any you have you have antibodies of certain parts of your brain it can cause pain anywhere
it can cause sensitivity issues it can cause the weirdest array of symptoms. And then there's a pathogen
associated immune reactivity screen for all sorts of different pathogens. So you have excess
amounts of these things it can be a major issue and then a array five is the multiple autoimmune
reactivity screen. Now these are all blood tests so you'd have to get a kit and you'll have to find
a place where you can get a draw. So getting this drawn and sent into Cyrex once you get the data
back it's very easy to read. You don't need me or a doctor to really go over the test with you
but what you need is what am I going to do about it now. And we'll have videos about that
in this module as well. What do I do what I have antibodies to different things? Well it's really easy
to understand what do I do if I have antibodies to food? Well I just have to stay off of those but
we'll have videos about that as well because I have different recommendations for that.
Remember why do we test four antigens because of my cardinal rule? When you fire an immune response
for whatever reason. I take a whole bunch of immune stimulants. I'm going to fire an immune response.
I have a cold. I'm going to fire an immune response. I'm exposed to strapped. I can fire an immune
response. When you do that your immune system will attack and kill many times. That would you have
antibodies against first? Of course it won't kill if you have antibodies against a chemical
but if you have antibodies against self tissue aka an autoimmune disease and you are taking a whole bunch
of immune stimulants you are going to be killing that tissue. That's why if you have an autoimmune
disease you have no business taking immune stimulants on a regular basis. You just don't. So even if you
have like high of Hashimoto's but I feel like I'm coming down with something and I'm getting sick
well you can take immune stimulants to help your body kill that virus or bacteria that you're
being exposed to. You feel like you're coming down with something different but you won't
better not be taking it on a regular basis. Taking immune stimulants on a regular basis will fire
an immune response and if you have antibodies against self tissue you are going to be killing yourself.
So I hit this over and over again in a bunch of the videos where we talk about autoimmune
life. I just can't say it enough. So that's why we look for antibodies. That's why you want to look
for antibodies and tests for antibodies. So you know what you're dealing with so you know how to move
forward. That's always a good thing to do. We'll have more videos on this so keep looking back at this
site and this module because we'll be continued and more stuff. Thanks so much. I'll be
praying for you. Bye bye.